All right, let me do a little bookend.
This is not a huge story by itself, but it's
really funny to watch.
I referred to it earlier.
Check this out.
Extremist Republican Devin Nunez called Lieutenant
Colonel Alexander Veneman, who was a key witness
yesterday in a, the Trump impeachment hearings.
Devin Nunez called him Mister and he was quickly
corrected by the Lieutenant Colonel.
Trump.
Didn't like it.
Republicans are all up in arms about this.
I love it.
Take a look at this.
Mr Veneman, you testified in your deposition
that you did not know the whistleblower, a
ranking member at Sal Lieutenant Colonel Vineman.
Please let Lieutenant Colonel Veneman.
You testified in the deposition that you did
not know who the whistleblower was, right?
I do not know who the whistleblower is.
That is how is it?
What I love about this story is that you can
actually hear in Devin Nunez voice and see
if you're watching the video.
He's visibly uncomfortable and shaken by this
correction from the Lieutenant Colonel.
Trump criticized Veneman for this disgraced
X New York city police department.
Uh, officer Bernie Kerik blasted Veneman for
this.
I respect this and I'll tell you why.
Their entire strategy is to discredit the
witnesses, uh, sail their character, attack
their credibility and their credentials and
whether they even were in a position to know
anything that they're testifying about.
So as funny and hilarious as it is to see
Devin Nunez get visibly nervous because of
this, this actually relates to their strategy.
This is the death of a thousand cuts.
Oh, you weren't on the call.
Oh, you're mr. rather than the active duty
member of the military Lieutenant Colonel,
that my party claims to support and respect
and defend and honor.
Oh, you didn't tell your supervisor about
this.
It's a thousand little cuts because that's
the only strategy they can employ and Lieutenant
Colonel Veneman did the right thing and it
threw Devin Nunez off for a few minutes.
Good for him.
And by the way, again for the party who claims
to respect veterans and treat them well.
This is an active duty member of the military
who was blown up in 2004 in Iraq.
He's in uniform, testifying under oath and
his title is Lieutenant Colonel.
It's on every TV screen.
It's on all of their notes.
It's not mr and Trump complained about it.
Who cares?
Nice job.
I loved seeing this.
Make sure that you're on the David Pakman
show newsletter.
Sign up@davidpakman.com on black Friday.
We will be emailing everybody on our newsletter
about a massive membership special that is
upcoming.
Sign up for the newsletter and let me know
what you think about mr Denman Lieutenant
Colonel Veneman by sending me [inaudible]
tweet at Dee Pacman